Public Sénat en partenariat avec le
Centre national du livre vous présente
au bonheur des livres
[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue dans l'émission
littéraire de Public Sénat au bonheur
des livres cette émission est un peu
particulière car c'est la dernière de la
saison est donc nous allons nous
émanciper de ces codes habituels pour
parler de l'écriture et de la lecture
qu'est-ce que c'est qu'un grand écrivain
comment devient-on un grand écrivain
pourquoi devient-on un grand écrivain
est-ce que le grand écrivain
d'aujourd'hui ressemble au grand
écrivain d'hier et les lecteurs est-ce
que les lecteurs sont toujours les mêmes
est-ce qu'ils ont changé nous allons
parler de cela et d'autres choses dans
cette émission que en clin d'oeil en
hommage à Julien GRAC nous avons
intitulé en lisant en écrivant et pour
en parler 4 invités au lieu de 2 régimes
atchondo qui préside le Centre national
du livre qui a été fondé en 1946 pour
soutenir le livre et la lecture madame
présidente bonsoir merci Noël Herp
écrivain auteur réalisateur comédien et
qui publie ma vie avec pivot avec
Bernard Pivot où il évoque l'importance
dans son existence de jeune homme du
célèbre animateur sous l'autorité morale
duquel d'ailleurs je suis heureux de
placer cette dernière émission bonsoir
Noël bonsoir et puis deux écrivains que
j'aime et que j'admire l'un et l'autre
d'ailleurs sont entrés un peu par
effraction dans la République parisienne
des lettres le 1er Jean Rouault parce
qu'il était kiosquié au moment où il est
apparu il y a 30 ans et le second
Louis-Philippe d'Alembert parce qu'il
est né et qu'il a grandi à 7000 km de
Paris en Haïti
Jean roux bonsoir nous allons commencer
avec vous et vous avez fait il y a 30
ans une apparition aussi fulgurante qui
n'attendu dans le firmament littéraire
en recevant le prix Goncourt pour votre
premier roman les champs d'honneur
publier de surcroît dans une maison les
éditions de Minuit qui n'étaient pas
tellement coutumières des prix mais
j'ajouterai que vous n'étiez pas
complètement raccord non plus avec cette
maison qui vous publiez
d'abord parce que vous renouillez avec
le récit alors que les éditions de
Minuit c'était la demeure du Nouveau
Roman et ensuite parce que sur le fond
en racontant votre famille dans la loi
inférieure il y avait un petit côté la
terre et les morts vous étiez en quelque
sorte anti moderne
on fait tous les thèmes du livre étaient
en réaction avec toute la modernité de
l'époque je parlais de la campagne et
alors la campagne c'était travail
famille Patrice c'était le retour à la
terre c'était Pétain
j'ai parlé de la famille qui était aussi
conspuée et famille je vous hais je
parlais de la religion l'opium du peuple
et je parlais de la guerre qui était
assimilé aux anciens combattants c'était
de les l'époque où Coluche Le Luron tout
ça fustiger les anciens combattants qui
étaient toujours là donc il s'agissait
ni un dernier loge de la campagne et de
la famille ni de du travail ni de la
guerre mais se trouve que j'avais
été élevé dans cette milieu-là et dans
cette mémoire là
le quand je commence à écrire je sais
que je suis adossé à deux guerres
derrière moi
la génération des grands-parents c'était
la première guerre des parents la
seconde des parents et que donc le il y
avait cette cette
idée qu'au fond qui avait une troisième
guerre en attente pour moi qu'on allait
me réserver c'est pour ça que j'ai
appelé un livre un peu la guerre
c'est-à-dire que la littérature comme
comme combat comme guerre aussi comme
guerre avec le réel on va on va y
revenir parce que après avoir achevé ce
cycle vraiment merveilleux consacré aux
autres ainsi que de 5 livres vous avez
entrepris un nouveau cycle la vie
poétique donc vous allez publier
d'ailleurs fin août le dernier volume
et qui est formidable aussi drôle que
profond vous avez dit quelque part je ne
sais plus où vous avez dit je ne je n'ai
pas mis des mots sur une histoire que
j'avais à raconter j'ai mis une histoire
sur des mots que j'avais à écrire
peut-être pas votre formule exacte mais
c'était l'idée c'est comme ça que vous
définissez l'écrivain c'est à dire que
il y a quelque chose de très mystérieux
et qu'on trouve dans Proust quand il dit
et ses rêves avertissaient que si je
voulais devenir écrivain il serait temps
de me demander ce que j'allais écrire
c'est comme s'il y avait un préalable de
poser à savoir je veux devenir écrivain
et qu'après la question se pose mais
enfin écrire quoi et moi je pense que je
viens de là après c'est à dire que
effectivement à un moment je me suis
demandé
on m'aurait reconnu comme écrivain 5
j'ai eu besoin d'écrire une ligne ça
m'allait mais on a même l'impression un
peu d'ailleurs vous voulez citer à la
manière des Confessions de Rousseau ou
de des mémoire d'outre-tombe de
Châteaubriand qu'au fond vous avez en
effet écrit tout le premier cycle sur
votre famille pour écrire le second sur
comment devenir écrivain comme si au
fond c'était le récit autobiographique
de votre vie d'écrivain qui était le but
ultime de votre travail
on lit de Rousseau et de Chateaubriand
c'est effectivement les les confessions
et mémoire d'outre-tom qui ne se
justifient que parce qu'il y a une œuvre
avant et comme si le l'oeuvre était le
récit de l'oeuvre c'est ça les
confessions c'est le moment
d'autre temps et donc il fallait poser
une oeuvre pour pouvoir faire le récit
de l'oeuvre donc l'oeuvre c'était avec
les champs d'honneur et puis les
premiers livres et le récit de l'oeuvre
c'est la vie politique mais en fait
c'est
une espèce de décalque de allez de
Rousseau et de Chateaubriand on
transmette en bonne compagnie
alors une autre chose me frappe c'est
que vous êtes de gauche vous constituez
le libéralisme vous avez écrit à l'Huma
avant de vous faire virer d'ailleurs
mais en même temps
votre cycle vous l'avez dit tout à
l'heure votre cycle familial sur la loi
enfin dans le Pays Nantais dans la loi
inférieure
émerge au moment où sur la scène
idéologique française on voit le retour
de la terre le retour de l'identité le
retour des racines le retour du peuple
est-ce que vous pensez qu'un écrivain
est le reflet même à son cœur défendant
des mouvements tectoniques de la société
ce cas ce qui est sûr c'est que le
lorsque je publie les champs de mer
c'est absolument à contre-courant c'est
une des raisons du succès du livre je
pense même et que tout soudain ça ça
évoquait pour un grand nombre de de
lecteurs leur enfance quand on demande à
Mitterrand qu'est-ce que le socialisme
il dit le socialisme c'est la ville
le capitalisme aussi quand même et sauf
que quand on renverse la formule
l'arrière ration c'est la campagne et
donc il y avait cette idée du progrès
moi je pense que le progrès est une
addiction c'est même la grande addiction
de
du 20e siècle
que que cette addiction du progrès avait
remisé comme ça tout se font la sur
lequel le pays s'était bâti et qui se
sentait non seulement abandonné mais
stigmatisé justement à travers Pétain et
la terre ne ment pas moi j'ai eu un
article du Monde pour mon deuxième livre
ou en citer la terre ne mentale
c'est-à-dire que on me faisait on me
faisait quasiment un héros du pétanisme
quoi heureusement comme vous le savez la
terre ne ment pas je crois que la
formule est d'Emmanuel Berne
d'un autre écrivain ma perception à moi
c'est que quand on se penchera dans
quelques décennies ou quelques siècles
peut-être sur les écrivains
d'aujourd'hui comme on le fait
aujourd'hui sur le 19e ce qui retrace
les sentiments de la société française
on pourra dire que il y a d'autres sans
doute mais il y a Houellebecq et yavu
est-ce que cette parenté vous choque non
parce que c'est une même critique au
fond de la monéternité quand je dis que
le progrès est une addiction c'est c'est
qu'on ne se rend pas compte puisque
c'est une addiction qui est considérée
comme
comme souhaitable
il y en a jamais assez et là on voit
bien que chaque fois que il y a un truc
qui va pas on demande à la science de
t'apporter le remède qui se trouve pire
que le mal des trois quarts du temps et
donc c'est cette idée que ce retourner
était parfaitement réactionnaire c'est
en ça que les chandonneurs ont été
considérés comme Asnières parce que je
me retournais alors qu'avant c'était
droit devant du passé faisant table rase
quand même alors ce qui est marrant
c'est que
la formule du passé faisant table rase à
as switcher comme ça très vite en devoir
de mémoire au moment du musée des 80
quand sont arrivés les grands procès
contre les collaborateurs mais au nom de
ce passé infamant on avait tout viré
comme si tout était mauvais etc Il t'a
on peut pas il s'agit pas dire qu'avant
c'était mieux mais avant il y avait plus
d'oiseaux avant la Côte d'Azur n'était
pas bétonné tout ce genre de choses
quand même vous êtes un peu
je pense que je suis là la gauche
réactionnaire
Louis-Philippe d'Alembert votre style
est bien différent de celui de Jean roux
et d'ailleurs vous racines sont toutes
différentes aussi puisque vous venez des
Caraïbes mais vous aussi vous êtes en
train de manière inattendue dans le
paysage littéraire car
vous venez d'Haïti vous avez d'ailleurs
une partie de votre œuvre en créole
notamment une partie de votre œuvre
poétique romanesque romanesque
et vous raconter dans votre premier
livre je crois de mémoire que c'est
perché dans un arbre en lisant que vous
trouviez la solitude donc vous aviez
besoin est-ce que ça veut dire que
l'écrivain doit s'abstraire du monde
pour le raconter
oui ça c'est très très bonne question
surtout venant d'Haïti c'est à dire que
où on accepte pas justement que
l'écrivain est soit hors du monde donc
pendant toute nos années de lycée par
exemple on nous a appris et qui avait
deux types de littérature qui était très
caricatural une littérature engagée ou
bien littérature d'évasion donc
l'écrivain ne doit pas être hors du
monde ne doit pas être dans sa tour
d'ivoire quelque part mais je crois que
l'écrivain tout écrivain peut-être il
exagère a besoin de solitude d'une
certaine façon pour travailler et ce qui
n'est pas toujours compatible avec une
société telle que la société haïtienne
par exemple à ce qui est l'oeuvre de
Jean roux est totalement enracinée en
tout cas la première partie dans son
pays nantais et puis c'est une œuvre qui
a une très grande forte connotation
autobiographique alors que vous c'est au
contraire vous voyagez en dehors de
votre premier roman qui est Haïti vous
avez écrit des romans qui sont situés
qui apporte au prince mais vous avez
remonté à New York sur la route de
l'exil entre la Pologne et Haïti sur la
route de l'émigration clandestine à
partir de l'Afrique à miwoki et votre
prochain livre se passe à Rome et chaque
fois ce sont en dehors du premier roman
ce sont des personnages qui de fiction
donc on a l'impression que Jean roux
revient toujours et toujours et de plus
en plus à lui-même alors que vous de
plus en plus vous vous éloignez de vous
au fond il y a un certain nombre de
thématiques qui sont là qui qui
reviennent qui que j'étais roge depuis
mes premiers livres c'est-à-dire la
migration par exemple
c'est quelque chose qui est très présent
même dans le premier roman qui a un
roman et qui parle de l'enfance donc il
y a la migration et à l'enfance et puis
donc qui est d'immigration dit forcément
et
errance d'une certaine façon
j'hésite à employer le terme exil qui
pour moi est très connoté politiquement
mais
il y a toujours l'idée de migration de
gens qui sont obligés de partir pour
aller trouver une meilleure vie ailleurs
ou pour des raisons politiques ou pour
des raisons économiques de plus en plus
aujourd'hui pour des raisons climatiques
mais tout ça ça d'une certaine façon me
renvoie à moi-même me renvoies à la
Caraïbe ou la Caraïbe c'est un
conglomérat de gens de peuple qui sont
venus d'ailleurs les autochtones ayant
été décimés il y a quelques siècles par
les Européens donc on est tous
d'ailleurs dans la Caraïbe donc on vient
tous de quelque part et il s'agit
maintenant d'essayer de prendre racine
là où on est sur cette Caraïbes mais
dans le vaudou par exemple haïtien on va
toujours il y a une expression qui a une
chanson même qui est très courante ou
qui dit qu'on est de passage mais de
passage sur cette terre physiquement
mais de passage aussi et quelque part
métaphysique il y a il y a une figure
récurrente tout de même dans votre œuvre
c'est la figure disons du persécuté le
petit black du ghetto le juif polonais
les femmes africaines enfin c'est
d'ailleurs jamais ni dolorisme ni
désespéré c'est pas c'est pas c'est pas
un champ du malheur c'est au contraire
souvent un champ de l'espérance mais
est-ce que vous considérez pour
reprendre l'expression de l'abbé Pierre
je crois que le votre rôle d'écrivain
c'est de donner de la voix à ceux qui
n'en n'ont pas c'est ça qui est qui est
sous-jacent c'est ce que disait Aimé
Césaire aussi un autre caribé
martiniquais et on a grandi dans cette
idée là c'est à dire tout à l'heure
j'entendais
écoutez Jean et parler en disant que
qu'est-ce qu'il faut écrire
c'était ça un petit peu l'idée et moi
c'était je savais ce qu'il fallait
écrire au départ c'est à dire donner la
voix au sans voix mais la question pour
moi en tant que quelqu'un c'était
comment l'écrire c'est à dire que je
savais dès le départ c'est-à-dire
j'étais très engagé aussi et
politiquement et mais comment écrire si
c'est toute la question en fait pour moi
de la littérature c'est à dire que c'est
ce qui va
permettre justement d'aborder un thème
comme l'enfance même si et cet enfant se
déroule au même endroit mais on ne va
pas l'écrire de la même façon et tout le
travail de l'écrivain vient de là et moi
j'ai grandi dans cette atmosphère là où
on te sommet presque de donner la voix
au sang voie c'était plus important mais
on oubliait le reste et c'est ce qui
fait que des années après certaines
auteurs qui m'avaient fasciné
adolescents et pour rester dans le
registre de la littérature française par
exemple Malraux
[Musique]
écrivain c'était une figure il
représente quelque chose c'est la raison
pour laquelle les gens se retournent et
vers lui en situation de crise et comme
c'est une société qui est souvent en
situation de crise donc on se retourne
constamment vers les écrivains avec le
risque justement et de
d'être toujours dans une forme
d'engagement et qui oublie l'essentiel
c'est à dire que on ne peut pas passer à
côté de cette société en crise
permanente mais en même temps on ne doit
pas oublier l'essentiel pour moi qui est
une forme à trouver en tant qu'écrivain
et c'est ce qui fait que et qui va me
différencier de gens ou qui va
différencer les gens de Houellebecq au
Houellebecq ou par exemple d'un autre
par exemple et qui chez vous à cette
particularité qui donne à mon avis donne
l'incroyable puissance de votre écriture
c'est que vous êtes à la rencontre de
disons du style français et de
l'écriture carré bon ou de la parole
carré ou de la parole créole
oui et mais je dirais un peu plus et
quand même parce que mes premiers ou mes
premières pas le français grandes amours
et littéraire au-delà de la poésie
c'était pas c'était pas les Haïtiens et
les Français c'était les j'en parle dans
mon dernier roman Une Histoire romaine
c'était les grands romanciers russes que
j'ai découvert par hasard et mon frère
qui avait une espèce de petit secrétaire
sous clé qui est gardé j'ai découvert et
tolstoïski mais j'étais fasciné et en
plus moi je me disais et pourquoi il les
avait gardé sous clés il y avait quelque
chose secret donc c'est de lire j'ai été
piégé mais après il y a eu bien entendu
les toute la littérature du boom
latino-américain donc on est les Garcia
marques et les variations ça les
cortaçante ainsi de suite donc
comment dire fascinés je trouvais et ce
dont on parlait et tout à l'heure la
narration et pour moi c'était c'était ce
qu'il fallait faire en tant romancier
alors le sacre de l'écrivain le sacre du
grand écrivain a connu un tournant avec
l'invention de la radio et de la
télévision et un tournant dans le
tournant avec apostrophe cette émission
de Bernard Pivot qui a régné en maître
sur la société télévision des gens de
lettres entre 1975 et 1990 et c'est cela
que vous évoquez Noël Herp ce moment
dans ma vie avec Bernard Pivot je crois
que ceux qui ont moins de 30 ans n'ont
aucune idée de ce qu'a pu être
à quel point cette messe du vendredi
soir pour des millions de spectateurs je
crois qu'en moyenne c'était 4 millions
c'est-à-dire à peu près le score d'une
finale de Roland-Garros l'impact de
cette émission sur les esprits de
l'époque et c'est exactement ce qui vous
est arrivé à vous
ça m'est tombé dessus oui comme comme la
foudre puisque finalement à cet âge-là
personnellement je m'intéressais pas
tellement la littérature je mets le
théâtre je lisais des pièce de théâtre
c'était mon truc j'étais un adolescent
un peu obsessionnel mais parents
d'ailleurs s'arrachait les cheveux parce
que je ne lisais pas de roman et
pourtant je regardais apostrophe parce
que tout d'un coup il y a eu cette mise
en scène de la littérature par pivot qui
a été quelqu'un qui a mis en scène les
écrivains a fait deux un peu les
performeurs de leur œuvre c'est-à-dire
en leur demandant de lire des extraits
de leur livre d'incarner leur livre de
les de les performer comme on dirait
aujourd'hui et en même temps la grande
innovation de pivot par rapport à des
vétérans qui avait été Roger Stéphane ou
pierre du maillet c'est c'est ou qui
interviewait des mandarins qui étaient
assis sur leur fauteuil et qui
généralement récitait un texte c'est
préparé à l'avance là c'était le clash
c'est-à-dire les étincelles que
formaient le débat c'est-à-dire qu'il
mettait ensemble des écrivains qui
n'avaient pas forcément des atomes
crochus et qui tout d'un coup allait se
rencontrer être un peu obligé de se lire
les uns les autres et dialoguer dans un
dialogue souvent conflictuel et c'était
donc ça on n'avait jamais vu ça vous
racontez que
[Musique]
ça par exemple vous jeune adolescent ça
vous permis de mieux comprendre ou même
d'assumer votre sexualité qui était un
peu réprimée dans votre famille parce
qu'il y avait devant vous des modèles il
y avait monté un lent raconté par cyprio
il y avait Julien Green il y avait
Dominique Fernandez même on vous
racontait qu'il a dit tout jeune homme
qui aujourd'hui n'assume pas son
homosexualité d'un lâche oui en fait
apostrophe n'a pas été tellement une
leçon d'écriture je lisais peu les
livres vendus ou promus apostrophes je
les achetais pas forcément sauf un livre
dont je parle qui est le livre de Jeanne
de Berg madame robb-grillet caché sous
Voilette Cérémonie de femmes qui étaient
un livre sur les femmes dominatrices qui
est beaucoup intrigué et donc voilà donc
il y avait aussi un garçon de 15 ans il
pense qu'à ça donc par définition voilà
je vais vers ce genre de livre mais
c'était pas forcément pour pour acheter
des livres d'ailleurs j'avais pas les
moyens mais c'était pour effectivement
essayer de trouver des modèles de vie et
des modèles de désir aussi c'est à dire
que les écrivains devenaient des
personnage et devenait des gens qui me
prenaient la main pour m'aider à vivre
ou m'aider à me définir parfois de
manière d'ailleurs réactive d'ailleurs
vous racontez assez de roulement que
c'est un peu comme gens qui disait tout
à l'heure que il aurait si on lui avait
permis de s'épargner d'écrire pour être
écrivain il aurait fait volontiers qu'il
y avait des personnages dont on avait
l'impression qu'il n'était des écrivains
que pour être apostrophe vous parlez de
Paul Guth de gens du Tour absolument et
même j'endormais son d'une certaine
manière pour moi j'adore mes sons avec
tout le respect que je dois à sa mémoire
pour moi est une création d'apostrophes
c'est le grand écrivain qui a été créé
par apostrophe parce qu'il avait un sens
de la formule les thé brillant il avait
il avait la tradition des salons il
avait la tradition des mots il y a
notamment ce fameux débat avec Roger
perfide qui avait été lui-même un
écrivain médiatique et donc c'est très
intéressant aussi de voir des écrivains
médiatiques détrôner d'autres écrivains
médiatiques et donc ce moment où Jean
d'Ormesson qualifie Roger perfide de
dame pipi et pour moi merveilleux ils
vont rosier pierrefites maintient son
fragile territoire de manière très
rhétorique donc il y a des guerres de
tranchées comme ça puisqu'on parlait de
la guerre il y a aussi voilà François
nourricier et Marc Edwarda il y a et
puis il y a aussi c'est très intéressant
parce qu'il y a aussi des rescapés de
l'ancienne génération par exemple des
gens de la collaboration qui était
encore présents apostrophe et qui qui
ont encore leur ronde serviette avec
Henri Lévy face aux Andes de Pierre
Laval ou à Maurice Bardet je plus
exactement qui voilà qui défend les
propos antisémites de brasillac donc il
y a des chocs de génération et c'est ça
que je pense qu'il me fascinait dans
apostrophe c'est c'est finalement ce
mélange de l'ancienne génération de la
nouvelle de la convention et de la
fantaisie de la norme et de la marge par
exemple Bukowski Bukowski qui arrive
complètement bourré alors j'ai fantasmé
dans mon livre je raconte que pivot l'a
fait virer du plateau c'est pas tout à
fait ça qui s'est passé je précise que
j'ai pas fait un livre d'historien ni un
livre de nostalgie
c'est vu c'est vu c'est c'est Bernard
Pivot vu de vous c'est pas du tout la
réalité de Bernard Pivot c'est c'est vu
par l'adolescent que j'étais j'ai essayé
de retrouver la fraîcheur
rétrospectivement on peut presque se
dire que au fond ce moment
d'acné de l'écrivain télévisuel a été
comme le chant du cygne et la figure du
grand écrivain quelque chose qui est né
au début des lumières disons et qui
s'est achevé avec pivot que à la fin
d'apostrophe va signer la fin de la
centralité de l'écrivain de la société
française pivot est à la fois quelqu'un
qui invente la médiatisation de
l'écrivain telle qu'on la connaît
aujourd'hui l'exhibition même
l'exhibition de soif jusqu'à l'obscénité
qu'on connaît aujourd'hui bon bah je
vais pas donner d'exemple ou de détails
mais enfin on voit bien aujourd'hui qu'à
travers Internet tout ça tout ça
l'écrivain est obligé d'exhiber sa vie
beaucoup plus que son œuvre au fond on
s'intéresse de plus en plus à ce que
Malraux justement appelé le tas de
petits secrets qui n'a quand même pas
beaucoup d'intérêt donc c'est le c'est
le triomphe de sainte-bauve un triomphe
posthume de sunbeuf et en même temps il
a été se faisant un fossoyeur de la de
la Société littéraire enfin un fossoyeur
de prestige c'est à dire qu'il a fait
une sorte de tombeau de on pourrait
regarder toutes les émissions de
l'apostrophe comme un vaste tomb niveau
de la littérature avec solaire savait
que avec Edmond de Charles Leroux des
gens comme ça qui représentaient une
société littéraire qui aujourd'hui a
disparu alors Louis-Philippe vous avez
publié après apostrophe donc la question
de c'est pas posée pour vous mais en
revanche Jean vous vous êtes passé à un
cheveu d'apostrophe cauchemar
quand on apprenait que j'écrivais
toujours le la formule récurrente
c'était alors quand est-ce que tu passes
à apostrophe tout ce qui donnait
évidemment envie d'étrangler la personne
puisque vous n'aviez pas encore publié
enfin bref et je signe
pour les champs d'honneur à minuit et en
même temps que je signe pivot annonce
qu'il arrête apostrophe donc je savais
avant que le livre paraisse que je ne
passerai jamais apostrophe
faudrait se remettre à je m'en suis
remis à Bernard il fallait quand on
était écrivain passé on n'était pas un
écrivain ce n'était pas passé
l'apostrophe de spectacle alors on a
parlé de la production des livres on a
parlé de la promotion des livres si je
veux dire avec pivot on va parler
maintenant de la réception des livres de
la lecture avec vous Madame présidente
Régine hadjo
d'abord les Français passaient pour de
grands lecteurs ils étaient je crois
dans les classements on était le 9e pays
du monde le deuxième pays européen par
le niveau de lecture c'est toujours vrai
on est toujours de grand lecteurs
le livre est toujours accompagné de
valeurs très positive quand on mène nos
enquêtes parce qu'on mène des enquêtes
c'est très sérieuse sur le rapport des
Français à la lecture il déclare
86% d'entre déclare lire régulièrement
probablement que dans le déclaratif on
déclare plus qu'on ne le fait réellement
mais pourquoi au fond c'est parce qu'on
considère que le livre et la littérature
apporte des vertus à la vie et signe
d'ouverture sur le monde d'émancipation
d'intelligence d'accès au savoir donc
dans les points positifs de nos études
le livre reste une valeur très précieuse
pour les Français il se déclare lecteur
c'est le cadeau de Noël
le premier cadeau de noël on a vu lors
de la décision de la couverture des
librairies et des librairies considérées
comme commerce essentiel des files
d'attentes à Noël assez longue de
Français qui préférait être dans une
file d'attente mais aller dans une
librairie indépendante comme un acte de
citoyen engagés et responsable donc ça
ce sont toutes les j'allais dire toutes
les valeurs positives de nos études et
puis bien évidemment le paysage est
toujours contrasté on n'est jamais dans
un monde de bisounours ce qui nous
inquiète nous au Centre national du
livre et c'est pour cela qu'on a
développer une politique j'allais dire
agressive bien sûr en tout bien tout
honneur pour développer la lecture c'est
que on se rend compte que le temps passé
sur des écrans
et cette fois supérieur autant passer
sur les livres en moyenne et 10 fois
supérieur chez les 15 25 ans vous
parliez de l'addiction au progrès et je
souscris totalement peut-être suis-je
aussi mon gaugistrer actionnaire j'en
sais rien en tous les cas ce qui est
certain aujourd'hui c'est qu'il y a une
addiction totale au téléphone portable
aux écrans de manière générale en
particulier au téléphone portable et qui
modifie littéralement et notamment chez
les jeunes le rapport à la lecture donc
au fond ce qu'on essaye de faire au
Centre national du livre j'espère qu'on
y parvient en partie même si c'est une
goutte d'eau dans l'océan de la
domination des écrans c'est c'est David
contre Goliath on est conscient on
essaye de de rendre au livre le plaisir
qu'il de donner à un jeune on essaye de
faire en sorte qu'il soit décomplexé
dans le fait de lire un livre on
développe l'audio aussi le livre audio
pour que les récits puissent être
entendus et donner envie de lire on est
très présent sur les réseaux sociaux
parce qu'il faut aller chercher les
jeunes où ils sont désormais
et nous organisons des festivals des
manifestations pour développer le goût
de la lecture et puis on travaille
beaucoup surtout avec l'Éducation
nationale où on en est à 1200 auteurs
que nous avons envoyé cette année enfin
envoyé que nous avons accompagné cette
année dans des collèges et lycées en
partenariat avec le Pass Culture car on
se rend compte et les enseignants nous
le disent que lorsque un jeune rencontre
un auteur vivant
ils se sont quand même beaucoup plus
concernés
dans le récit dans l'échange et
probablement dans la lecture
d'oeuvre contemporaine qui donne à voir
ce que les jeunes aujourd'hui traversent
aussi petite question on est on a on est
le pays qui a fondé l'Académie française
en
1634 36 36 on est le pays qui est le
premier en 1789 à consacré la liberté
méditer on est le premier qui en
17811 à inventé le droit d'auteur enfin
je pourrais continuer la longue liste du
travail de la puissance publique au
service de l'écriture qui a donné le
sentiment pendant très longtemps que au
cœur de ce qu'on appelle l'exception
culturelle française il y avait le livre
qu'il était vraiment sur le piédestal au
milieu de l'action publique et qu'on
était la patrie entre toutes les autres
des écrivains est-ce que c'est encore
vrai est-ce que le livre encore dans
l'action des pouvoirs publics la place
qu'il a eu historiquement dans notre
pays
oui le livre à cette place là alors
comme la production d'un livre est
beaucoup moins coûteuse que la
production d'un film de cinéma d'une
série ou d'autres industries d'autres
objets d'industrie culturelle et
créatifs ce n'est pas le secteur qui
coûte le plus cher en revanche il est
très défendu et aujourd'hui alors même
si on en a célébré des 40 ans du prix ni
du livre il y a 40 ans le fait d'avoir
instauré le prix unique du livre a
permis à la France de rester un pays
exceptionnel par la densité par exemple
de ces libériens dépendante et cette
année on a ouvert en 22 142 librairies
dans dans la moitié ce sont installés
dans des petites communes de moins de
15000 habitants et le quart dans des
communes de moins de 5000 habitants avec
des vrais changements de vie beaucoup de
Parisiens qui ont décidé de quitter la
ville après le covid qui a beaucoup
changé le rapport à la à la ville de
Paris aux grandes métropoles donc on a
encore cette spécificité
on est un pays vraiment de l'exception
culturelle sur le livre encore en
revanche il est évident que si la
puissance publique ne prend pas
conscience de maintenant
le message à délivré de l'importance de
la lecture pour sauver nos adolescents
parce qu'il est question là c'est même
plus une question de fenêtre ouverte sur
le monde de poésie d'oralité de la
famille des racines de l'enfance il est
question de de santé psychique je pense
pas qu'on puisse être un adolescent et
un futur adulte si on a jamais rien lu
et qu'on ne lira jamais de sa vie et là
nous sommes inquiets et d'ailleurs les
médecins le sont il y a de plus en plus
d'études des pédopsychiatres et des
neurologues qui disent que la
fréquentation addictive des écrans
modifient la construction de cerveau la
plasticité et je crois qu'aujourd'hui on
est dans un même dans un problème de
santé physique et mental je te disais
déjà que le livre est la meilleure
médicament contre la non-rasthén alors
vous vous agissez mais vous célébrez
aussi le livre vous allez vous allez
notamment en ce moment vous avez vous
êtes en train d'organiser un événement
autour du livre racontez-nous ça en
quelques secondes
je crois c'est la 9e édition d'un
festival qui s'appelle parti en ligne
qui s'adresse aux adolescents aux jeunes
mais aussi aux familles 800 auteurs
présents un livre au Drôme qui est un
parc d'attraction littéraire qui se
promène en France des siestes
littéraires des contes racontés à voix
haute des ateliers d'écriture des
ateliers de de dessin et d'illustrations
et puis surtout 800 auteurs qui sont sur
5500 évènements en France pour aller à
la rencontre de tous ces jeunes et des
livres offerts des chèques livres au
fait des chèques livres offert aussi
pour que les jeunes aillent en librairie
acheter des livres bravo merci ne lâchez
pas l'affaire cette émission s'achève et
avec elle la saison entière donc vous
pourrez revoir non seulement cette
émission mais toutes les précédentes sur
la plateforme numérique publique
je voudrais vous remercier tous les
quatre et
à travers vous vos 52 prédécesseurs
d'avoir répondu à mon invitation je
voudrais recommander évidemment la
lecture du livre de Noël RP ma vie avec
Bernard Pivot chez plein jour je
voudrais recommander puisque l'été et le
moment
idoine pour cela la lecture de l'oeuvre
complète de Jean Rouault et de l'oeuvre
complète de Louis-Philippe d'Alembert je
vous assure que ça vous le détourne mais
vous dire aussi d'être attentif parce
qu'en août va sortir de gens ou comédie
d'automne qui est de Louis-Philippe
d'Alembert une histoire romaine qui sont
deux petits diamants le premier pas
petit du tout d'ailleurs le premier
parce que Jean Rouault il raconte ses
relations avec les Jérôme Lindon et son
Goncourt et ses savoureux notamment et
le second parce que dans lequel
Louis-Philippe fait un portrait de deux
femmes
de plusieurs femmes en fait mais de deux
familles l'une aristocratiques et
l'autre juive à Rome et c'est un très
joli portrait de ces femmes mais aussi
de Rome qui est un passage obligé pour
tout grand écrivain
Châteaubriand standard Zola et
maintenant Louis-Philippe Dumas et
maintenant Louis-Philippe d'Alembert
les sept collines de Rome je voudrais
remercier toute l'équipe sur ce plateau
et en régie qui a réalisé cette émission
toute cette année je voudrais remercier
Christopher Baldelli Emmanuel Guilcher
Fabrice Gabriel et Marine Lebon avec qui
nous avons conçu cette émission chaque
semaine
enfin je voudrais vous remercier vous
qui nous avez suivi chaque semaine et en
étant plus nombreux chaque mois ou
chaque semaine à chaque émission et qui
m'avait souvent témoigné dans des
rencontres de hasard dans la rue le
plaisir que vous preniez à cette
émission et surtout l'utilité qu'elle
avait pour vous et donc ça m'a
évidemment
conforté dans l'idée que c'était une
œuvre à accomplir voilà passez donc un
bel été avec les livres c'est
merveilleux compagnons merci et bonsoir
[Musique]
Public Sénat en partenariat avec le
Centre national du livre vous a présenté
au bonheur des livres